take two for NASA the space agency is
counting down to another attempt at
launching its unmanned Artemis Rockets
later today the most powerful rocket
NASA has ever built was supposed to
blast off on a test flight to the moon
and back last Monday but that liftoff
was scrubbed due to technical problems
Mark Strassman is at the Kennedy Space
Center in Florida where the window to
launch Artemis opens in just a few hours
today Mark the big question how is it
looking right now
well morning Jeff it's not looking great
NASA has a problem this massive rocket
has sprung a leak it's in the engine
section which is at the very bottom of
the rocket and it surfaced a couple of
hours into the fueling process and
there's no question this is a problem
that NASA has to solve if it hopes to
make its two-hour launch window this
afternoon starting at 2 17 Eastern Time
it was after the fueling was over this
past Monday when NASA had to scrub the
first schedule launch the problem then
was temperature gauges showed one of the
core stages four engines failed to cool
properly NASA now believes a faulty
sensor was to blame if that sensor goes
out again today their plan is to ignore
it today's weather forecast 60 percent
go for launch to start the two hour
window 80 percent toward the end of it
and now that we're in a holiday weekend
the crowds are expected to be even
bigger than they were for the first
schedule launched on Monday local
tourism officials expect somewhere
between 200 000 and 400 000 people to
line the causeways of beaches hoping to
get a glimpse of the launch and the last
thing that any of these people want to
see Jeff is a is a fuel leak that scrubs
the launch for a second time
but I'm sure they also want NASA to be
safe I know a lot of people have been
looking forward to this still Mark if if
it doesn't happen this afternoon what
what's next
couple options Monday Tuesday and if it
doesn't happen by then then they have to
roll the rocket back to the garage the
Vehicle Assembly Building Hope for later
this month or even next month so if it
doesn't happen by Tuesday there really
is going to be a somewhat significant
delay
okay Mark Strassman thank you very much
I know a lot of people as we said you
know they really want to see this but as
somebody said this morning they're okay
with NASA waiting I mean they spent four
billion dollars on this this is not a
manned mission but the next one will be
um so
I I just thought it was interesting that
if it doesn't work out by Tuesday you
take it back to the garage yeah and and
I wonder what the bill is for the
tune-up or the fix it back at the garage
I mean how much more money is going into
the delay it's not the 1999 oil change